hello and welcome to you can and must
understand synthetic biology
I'm Andrew Hessel and I'll be walking
you through a presentation on this new
and exciting technology the title of
this talk is actually taken from a very
influential zine that came out in 1974
by Theodore Nelson called you can and
must understand computers now and it was
really a publication that got many
people interested in computers and media
and of course we know where that took us
by way of introduction I'm a
microbiologist and a genetic scientist
my background is in genome mapping I
started doing genome mapping of bacteria
in the late 1980s early 1990s really
some of the first sequencing projects
and more recently I work with a company
called Autodesk Autodesk is a company
that makes software for design and
engineering visualization and simulation
it's usually best known for its AutoCAD
line of products which are used for the
development of buildings and other
complex systems cars vehicles etc but
recently Autodesk has started to explore
the world of biological design and
molecular design I'll tell a little bit
more about that later in the
presentation and how it lives in I'm
also a faculty at something called
singularity University if you're not
familiar with singularity University
it's based at NASA research park in
Mountain View California in the Bay Area
and it's a startup University that was
founded in 2009 really with a completely
different vision for teaching students
about technology it was recognized that
by a number of people in the Bay Area
that most schools were we're backwards
looking and really weren't doing a good
job at teaching people about really fast
changing technologies like computers and
so the whole idea of being able to teach
about exponential trends you know
something we're pretty familiar with in
the world of electronics because Moore's
law and the idea that computing power
doubles every 18 months or so is pretty
much baked into the digital world it was
it was realized that you need to teach
people about exponential trends because
if they're not intuitive as as as Peter
Diamandis one of the one of the founders
of the university likes to point out if
you take 30 linear steps you know
exactly where you are you basically walk
across a room when you take 30
exponential steps you've taken over a
billion steps and you've walked around
the earth multiple times it's we're just
not trained to think exponentially very
easily so we teach people how to be
leaders in exponential technologies and
how to apply exponential technologies in
the world in a number of different areas
including including water use global
health energy etc my particular area is
in bioinformatics and biotechnology and
here I like to point out to people that
really it's one of the first exponential
technologies that cells are effectively
living computers and our genomes are our
operating systems and starting to build
on that foundation an understanding of
how genetic technologies are starting to
mature and be advanced in this ties in
with synthetic biology but first before
I go into that I just want to do a quick
review of really what exponential
technologies look like and I'll use
computing as an example because they're
so familiar this is a picture of the
first transistor and it was developed in
1957 in Bell Labs it really looks like
something that was hacked together in
the basement out of out of old parts but
this is this is the foundation of
probably one of the largest industries
in the world today digital technologies
and there's a whole history of these
technologies being developed in Silicon
Valley it's a fascinating story but
ultimately very quickly we advanced
beyond the transistor into semiconductor
technologies we're where the entire
computer was was manufactured on a chip
this was a powerful change in the
economics of computers and it really
sparked a number of innovators famously
Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs founded
Apple Computer in a garage which is
pretty remarkable people like Bill Gates
and Paul Allen founded software
companies Microsoft and very quickly we
progressed into these computers which
were once only accessible by elites in
industry and academia and the nura Terry
you know these computers showing up in
the home and being used by individuals
and of course this caused a massive
expansion of hardware networks software
etc creativity really you know in the
explosion of the web of course Larry and
Sergey came along to Google because it
was hard to navigate the web and built a
powerful enterprise around this Mark
Zuckerberg a few years later recognized
that it's really not computers that want
to connect it's people that want to
connect really powerful shift in the
understanding around networking and and
more recently Jack Dorsey and Twitter
you know creating essentially a nervous
system for these for these technologies
now this this digital technology goes
very deep it's and it's not it's
bi-directional today we're actually
digitizing the world
just about every major city is being
digitized by laser scanning photography
satellite photography etc we're mapping
the world in completely new ways we're
also learning how to map individuals at
high resolution this is something we do
at Autodesk and we're able to apply
unique characters and movies that never
existed before this is modeling and
simulation that life science only dreams
about but it's also moving down to a
consumer level this is this is scanned
artwork from the Asian Art Museum in San
Francisco just done with an iPhone very
quickly it can be digitized on the cloud
and and turned into models it can be
manipulated digitally very easily and
actually turned back into reality with
things like the MakerBot and other 3d
printers so we're getting a full
iteration a cycle here of being able to
scan the world be able to manipulate it
digitally and turn it back in the
reality you know through our computing
technologies that have been evolving so
quickly but what I like to point out to
people and is that life living things is
really the first exponential technology
and and the technology that is
ubiquitous to this planet hourly is all
these computer and hardware tools that
we've engineered are fantastic but but
life is really the first exponential
technology and it's a complicated
technology and my I studied ecoli and
Salmonella for many years as part of the
genome projects and was always
fascinated by the complexity of what we
consider to be this simple organism
ultimately David Goodsell has a
beautiful book on the machinery of life
and depicting this organism and as you
go through these illustrations and start
diving into E coli one realizes it is
massively complex
it is a self-assembling you know
self-reproducing system that's quite
beautiful and of course we see this
under the microscope with bacteria as it
starts to divide from one cell and
ultimately through truly exponential
growth to produce billions of cells in
24 hours now what I started realizing
working at the intersection of computers
and life science a long time ago I was
one of the first people doing
essentially bioinformatics was that
there was that there was a relationship
that that was appearing that in in in my
world where I could see the physical
complains that we were creating with
computers had analogs in life science
components were really the individual
proteins these circuits that we are
making you could think of as basic
metabolism and if you could put enough
circuits together you really got pretty
much in the entire cellular metabolism
and if this was encapsulated and
operating right you have a living cell
and of course cells have their own
architectures tissues and organs and
which make up us so really one can think
of life multicellular life as really
being a network of living computers in
the case of a human and you know
hundreds of billions of these computers
and it's networked all the way down it's
essentially information processing all
the way down today it's quite intuitive
because we were so used to having these
networks these computer networks around
us that it's that people coming into
life science and having life science
explained to them through the
architectures of computing it becomes
very very straightforward and
understandable to them
now if you take an e coli bacterium and
you step on it you can release its
genome so to speak this is the famous
micrograph this is you know both four
and a half billion mega bits of genetic
code more than sufficient to encode a
free living cell when I first saw this
picture I saw this image and I found it
it just burned into my brain and I
realized I want to understand how how
this information is organized now that
was really bioinformatics and what we
today look at is systems biology and
this is largely mediated through
sequencing technologies and and
bioinformatics today sequencing
technologies are very powerful this is
the machine called the Ion Torrent it is
it is a desktop DNA sequencer it's very
fast it's not too expensive it can do
about a human genome in a day based on
chip technologies this is we've seen a
massive increase in our ability to read
or scan DNA extremely quickly we've also
started to write DNA the tools are still
have become are becoming digital and
this is really the foundation of
synthetic biology being able to do
digital manipulation of DNA and instead
of traditional traditionally using
recombinant techniques to to build our
designs effectively the equivalent of
taking preformed words and scissors and
glue and creating new programs synthetic
biology is rooted in less analog
technologies here's here's how here's
the type of equipment one actually needs
to do genetic engineering in the
classical form but what's happening and
really the foundation of synthetic
biology
is that the actual printing of DNA can
be done digitally so now we have the
ability to read DNA very quickly to
analyze it computationally and now to
actually print it using companies like
DNA 2.0 gene art IDT and and other
companies that are specializing as
essentially DNA printers now if you
haven't seen a DNA DNA printer before
here's a unit that that's quite advanced
this is an array synthesizers a chip
gets loaded into this device and they
have different densities of chips the
chips are electronically controlled and
they grow up they grow on these chips
individual strands of DNA that are
precise to the base pair these are there
these are then assembled to create
longer constructs and these array
synthesizers are allowing us to get to
very very low cost per base in DNA
synthesis but the the take-home message
here is that essentially DNA synthesis
has become push-button and this is a
remarkable change for anyone that's been
in the biotech industry before really
doing this type of manipulation through
a computer using just a computer was
unheard of a decade and a half ago and
now essentially anyone that has access
to a credit card a computer in the
internet and some of these DNA synthesis
technologies essentially has the power
of a major biotechnology company the
foundational technologies anyway at
their disposal what's quite interesting
too is that the economics of of reading
analyzing and ultimately printing DNA
are truly on an exponential in fact a
super exponential curve this is the
first person to really start
quantifying this was Rob Carlson his
offense he's one of the early synthetic
biologists and this curve this graph of
the cost of DNA sequencing and synthesis
over time is it started to be called the
Carlson curve really the biological
equivalent of Moore's Law the blue line
here represents the cost of sequencing
which is which has seen dramatic
improvements up to five times the pace
of Moore's law over on a year-to-year
basis and the yellow line represents the
cost of DNA synthesis which has been
following exponentially and looks too
far super exponentially soon over over
the next few years so really the cost of
doing this is is getting cheaper each
each year and it's getting faster as the
technology is improved we're still
limited in terms of the overall size of
the program that we can create but but
there's improvements coming down the
path on that so you know what what does
one do with push-button DNA well one of
the first examples that we started to
see in the design space was that it
could be used to do DNA origami this is
essentially using synthetic DNA staples
to bend a larger fragment of DNA into
different shapes this is precise
molecular scale control using synthetic
DNA to do manipulate matter at the nano
scale I particularly like the happy face
I think this is it made me happy to see
that this is work of it was published
around 2005 and 2006 by power Rothman
it's been extended into three dimensions
the what's fascinating about this work
is that again DNA is just being used as
a structural material but the the
biophysics of the material are so well
known
that it can be designed on computer and
turned into these shapes very very
reliably and and in fact these shapes
are starting to get functionalized in in
different ways now there's been some
tremendous work coming out of the visa
Institute there where groups have made
things like cancer fighting robots by
functionalizing some of these shapes of
in in new ways this is a technology
that's still in its infancy but it's
moving again very quickly because we
have these computer-based design tools
and a printer but DNA of course is
typically used for genetic engineering
and now that genetic engineering has
gone digital we've been creating a new
community of programmers so to speak
this is a picture of the students that
that have reached the finals in a
program called
I gem or International genetically
engineered machines which is a program
that was started at MIT in 2003 to Train
synthetic biologists or essentially
these these young engineers that wanted
to go out and do genetic engineering but
using standardized and modular parts and
that are ultimately being printed and
synthesized so this is really biological
programming to date about 12,000
students have been through the ijen
program many of them have the earlier
ones have received their PhDs and are
now taking positions throughout the
world and they're they're in high demand
and their capabilities are quite
remarkable these were some students from
Cambridge a number about three or four
years ago that we're engineering ecoli
that that would glow very very brightly
with the idea that one day they would be
able to make glow-in-the-dark
trees wonderful technologies but it's
not just come today there's over 200
different institutions
around the world that participate in the
iGEM program that's one of the main
gateways into the field of synthetic
biology but there's also a large number
of high school teams that are coming in
as well so this is a technology like
computer programming that's getting
pushed down to lower and lower levels
because the tools are making it easy to
access and of course the costs are still
falling back I started to see evidence
of this back in 2008 with the formation
of a group called do-it-yourself biology
which essentially grew out of the iGEM
community and students that said you
know we love doing this so much we don't
really want to do it as a once a year
competition we want to make it part of
our everyday lives and starting to play
with these things and learn about
different aspects of life science even
if we're not going to be full-time in in
learning life sciences and this
organization has grown remarkably again
exponentially over over the years and as
now there are thousands of people on the
nail lists that are actively engaged and
there's and and many projects being done
as I also started to see the appearance
of people taking DIY bio into the real
world in starting small companies and
this is a fellow by the name of Cathal
Garvey and Ireland a very active member
of the DIY community that created a
licensed biotech company in a spare
bedroom in his mother's home he actually
does genetic design and sells his
designs and loves making equipment and
hacking equipment and a very staunch
supporter of open technologies in life
science it but it's moved beyond just
individuals with a passion to groups
working together in communities and this
has been we've seen evidence of this
with appearance of labs like this this
is a community lab in Brooklyn called
gem space that
uses essentially a gym membership as
their as their business model for about
$100 a month you could become a member
of the lab take various courses and
learn how to do various types of genetic
engineering
there's projects across the range of
life science in this and they're
certainly not the only lab any longer
there's a lab and malesko is called bio
curious that's that's quite large
there's a new one that's just popped up
in in Harlem and around the world there
are no dozens of these community biotech
labs so there's just like we saw in
computing it's moved from from new
specialized communities to to highly
trained individuals with a passion that
to share it and grow community to
essentially garage biotechnology and now
to more of a grassroots growing
exponential community of developers this
is also starting to move into this this
activity is moved into into the funding
realm as well I showed you the the
students at Cambridge that did the
glowing that want to make glowing trees
one day this is a group that decided
they'd actually try and do it or take
the first step anyway they started it
they they put a project on Kickstarter
which is a crowdfunding site on the web
saying that they wanted to make
glow-in-the-dark plants plants that that
ultimately would had a Lucifer A's gene
and they received 8,000 backers and
almost a half a million dollars in
funding it's a little controversial
because they plan to give out seeds as
part of the rewards for their funders
but and but it's legal and it's
certainly changing the discussion around
around biotechnology and the release of
genetically modified organism organisms
even if you
even if they're benign but this is this
is really all early markers and
indicators of fundamental change coming
into life science we're also seeing that
some of the students that came through
the IgM programs over the years and they
were actually training students when
they finished their their doctoral work
they decided to to not go into
postdoctoral fellowships but into
industry again with a very open eatos
and this is a this is a picture from
gingko Bioworks located in Boston the
founders are are some of the original
instructors of the ijen program their
goal is is to unabashedly to genetically
engineer organisms this is a strata from
their website their aim is to be able to
do complex metabolic engineering in the
in e.coli on on contract and create new
essentially new metabolic end products
that had been tuned for various
feedstocks and customers very ambitious
this type of engineering ten years ago
would would have required another order
of magnitude of investment and and and
an R&D activity so this is really a
powerful step an area I've been watching
very quickly because it's still
expensive and slow to engineer a microbe
is as the development of viral
engineering using these technologies the
first synthetic virus was booted up
about in 2002 by Eckert Limor he
synthesized they did the
proof-of-concept it was the first fully
synthetic genome he synthesized that
polio virus genome and demonstrated that
it could be booted up and make active
particles that was very controversial at
the time but since then dozens of
viruses have been and
year using synthetic biology techniques
and for applications including
Diagnostics
more recently vaccines and I think very
soon we'll start to see a number of new
applications in therapies cancer
therapies and eventually gene therapies
as these get robust currently today's
DNA synthesis cost making a large
something like an adenovirus genome
would cost about $7,000 Dental virus
adenovirus having a genome of about
thirty-five thousand base pairs but we
can quickly see as these technologies
fall in cost
we're you know it could be as little as
under a hundred dollars in the next few
years to do this type of engineering in
a very rapid and high-throughput way so
this is forcing a rethink of the
application space and also how this type
of industry should be monitored
regulated etc quite a fascinating area
that I've been very closely tracking but
has tremendous applications just because
it can rapidly iterate I'd like to point
out that it's probably in some ways more
amenable to regulation and monitoring
than virology of days past because it's
being done through a digital medium so
there's there's a lot of recording of
the transactions probably the most
sophisticated use of synthetic biology
to date has been craig Venter and ham
Smith at Synthetic Genomics in the J
craig Venter Institute they demonstrated
three years ago now that they could
synthesize and assemble a complete
microbial genome this made world
headlines but it's I think it's telling
this is about a million base pairs you
know I think it's telling that this work
has
not yet been repeated even three years
later by to my knowledge in fact this is
as to my knowledge the only synthetic
bacterium that has been built from
scratch
last month in in London there was the
sixth conference ever in synthetic
biology known as SB 6.0 the keynote
speaker was a fellow by the name of
Chris Voigt who has been working to
create high-throughput ways to
re-engineer not whole genomes but
sections of genomes that we call
operands and and developing an
architecture a programming language and
ultimately the automation to do this
chris has been working to re-engineer
nitrogen fixation the nitrogen fixation
cluster from Klebsiella and and
essentially poured it to e.coli quite
it's a large block of DNA about 20,000
base pairs it's it's it's been
refactored the original control elements
and in the wild-type Geno have been
stripped away and and very robust
switches and other control mechanisms
have been imported the first time he did
this this actually lowered the fitness
of that particular operon but in his
most recent work has been able to to
essentially re-engineer it up to wild
type specifications again this is really
powerful tools for metabolic engineering
in in living creatures and getting and
under not necessarily always
understanding what nature created but
being able to apply engineering rules to
make it more easy for humans to
understand manipulate and ultimately
optimize the systems
moving beyond bacteria which is still a
you know organisms that are unfamiliar
to most people
there's baker's yeast yeast is for the
last several years there's been a
project underway to build a a synthetic
yeast genome from scratch this is an
ambitious project because the genome is
much larger the chromosomal structures
are much more complicated it's being
pretty well funded now and it's moving
at a pretty good pace it's a partnership
with the United States and with vgi the
sequencing and synthesis powerhouse in
China what I find fascinating about the
yeast engineering work is that is that
people are very familiar with yeast
because of course it's the foundation of
making bread and beer and beer is I like
to think of as the one of the top three
most important liquids on the planet
some believe beer has actually been
responsible for most of human
civilization I'm not so sure about that
but what I do know is that it's getting
accessible to bioengineers this is an
eye gem team from last from 2012 that
from Munich that engineered four
different beers as part of their summer
long project they made they introduced a
protein based sweetener a protein based
flavor into the architecture of the beer
a cancer drug and what I and then a
stroke of genius the entire bio
synthetic pathway for caffeine what a
group a few years ago at Rice University
in 2008 it also engineered
cancer-fighting beer but what was
remarkable at this group from Germany
was they actually made the beers and
filtered out the yeast so it's not a
genetically modified organism and
ultimately had some taste testings done
with the beers as well so this is this
is I think we're going to see a lot of
engineered yeast
moving forward and potentially a new bio
beer industry starting to emerge with
some very different flavors and perhaps
even therapeutic qualities to the beers
nutraceutical so to speak and very
likely a few recreational x' as well so
now we've covered basically that you've
got DNA synthesis allowing to do
structural engineering at the nano scale
cellular programming at the nano scale a
reprogramming synthetic cell
construction synthetic virus
construction you know after you know
this is still being done pretty much at
the single cell level what happens when
you want to go multicellular well
multicellular engineering is actually
fairly difficult one of the things I've
been tracking very closely is the use of
bio printers to externalize the
positioning of individual cells
essentially taking development into a
much more human controllable process
this is this is work done by a company
one of the companies at the forefront of
the space is called organovo that I've
been tracking over the years and
organovo buys this 3d printer that is
capable of printing cells dozen their
core technologies around is around cell
engineering and today they're
successfully making synthetic liver
tissues that they're able to sell to
pharmaceutical companies for
standardized toxicity testing etc I
think as this technology gets more
robust and cheaper we'll see a lot of
new applications than this people are
already talking about making synthetic
leathers and synthetic meats as the cost
drop for two so that we can essentially
grow fewer cows
but after that point you know there's
even a possibility of using synthetic or
muscle cells that are deposited by
something like a 3d printer to also make
for robot locomotion very small robots
and controllable as well so some cyborg
technologies so these are powerful
foundational tools but some of the key
that I want to point out here is it's
basically digital design coupled with
some sort of digital printing that can
be controllable this is really the
foundation of a lot of synthetic biology
another interesting application is
really just backups DNA turns out to be
one of the most robust materials for
digital storage George Church recently
demonstrated that it can be used as
digital backups for computers but we're
also learning that we can go back in
time and actually start seriously
thinking about D extinct increasing
extinct animals and we'll probably see
this technology used as as a way of of
preventing extinctions and enhancing
conservation efforts as we move forward
but this is really the forward fringe of
this technology I like to point out you
know in computers we say things get
faster cheaper better smaller and
certainly in the short term these
technologies and genetics are going to
be allowed things to go faster cheaper I
don't know if they'll necessarily be
better so I usually say faster cheaper
weirder because we're we're starting to
see people will explore very different
spaces than could be explored by the
conventional biotechnology industry or
even academia in the past because
because they've essentially the cost
have reached a toy or hobbyist level you
know I like to point out that it's
really just going to be simplified to
design on computer print on some printer
and ultimately if if it's legal and safe
to do so shifts to the end
of course this is this is prompting a
rethink of of biology and biological
regulation pretty much at all levels
Marc Goodman a cybersecurity expert and
I wrote a piece for The Atlantic last
year discussing how we really need to
start thinking about things a little
differently and it was called hacking
the presidents in DNA and we meant to be
provocative because because we spend a
fortune on on biosecurity but how is
biosecurity changing in the world where
these technologies are going digital I
don't necessarily think it's going to be
make things less safe in the short term
in fact I think today the biggest risks
in the digital world come from computer
technologies but we have all if we look
at life as a as another programming
medium I think we really need to start
considering what some of the that the
dynamics that we've seen appear in the
digital world of computing are going to
appear in life science you know and this
is are things like privacy issues things
like spamming issues and hacking of
various systems so expect to see a lot
of social dynamics in the in the field
of synthetic biology as these
technologies continue to advance and
emerge very quickly my own application
focus though and my interest in this
area is really rooted in the
understanding is in drug development my
background was with a major
biopharmaceutical company and after I'd
spent several years with them I realized
we have a challenge in that are the the
outputs of the of the pharmaceutical
industry globally has been declining as
measured by drugs per billion dollars
invested in R&D and this is a universal
problem it's not confined to one country
or one company it's really the global
industry isn't a technology per se may
use technology but the output
are actually appearing and taking the
market not fastly better cheaper but
actually slower much more expensive to
develop and and a lot of me too or very
incremental improvements to the drugs so
this is a I believe that that this trend
will has the potential to be reversed
through core of fundamental technologies
like synthetic biology that changed the
economic paradigms potentially to the
point that we can actually consider
making personalized medicines I mean
truly n of one medicines which can then
disrupt things like the regulatory and
and clinical trial paradigm so I expect
to see a lot of activity in the drug
development area particularly in with
respect to rare diseases and stage
cancers that aren't responding to or
cancers that aren't responding to
conventional treatments and and other
other areas that are just confined to
individuals and fundamentally on a more
philosophical level as as you know
really this is in some ways is the end
of natural selection because as we as
these technologies get cheap and
potentially synthetic buy out synthetic
genomes on the scale of a human or a
plant or an animal could fall
dramatically over the next decade or two
to the point where they cost a few
dollars or pennies I like to say that
the bottom of DNA synthesis is is
essentially the cost of cell division
with one of our own cells which of
course is trivial all the machinery is
is already in ourselves so this could
really represent a the end of natural
selection in a way because human
intention could be intrinsically linked
to the generation or conservation or in
fact the extinct ting of living
creatures on their planet so along with
computing this is a really fundamental
technology that we're seeing changes
so just to summarize them synthetic
biology of you know many people argue
about the definitions but I think this
is a pretty good one from the recent
report from the National Academies a
synthetic biology is an emerging
discipline that combines both scientific
and engineering approaches to the study
and manipulation of biology the
scientific approach is really under is
really the research aspect the reverse
engineering of existing metabolism
learning that to apply it to the
engineering and manipulation of
biological systems and I think this is
moving very quickly because it's
ultimately additive its most basic it's
really just genetic engineering only
only empowered and done with digital
tools so it's nothing new but the way we
do it is completely new and we've seen
these shifts before in the past with
things like word processing other
digital technologies already there is a
global diverse and highly interconnected
community and synthetic biology they
communicate using electronic systems
they are sharing data using electronic
systems so it's really built on the
foundation of conventional IT and I
believe that it is potentially
unpredictable just as some of the new
applications of digital technologies are
still surprising to us today and because
of its unpredictable it has the
potential to be highly disruptive I'll
end with this statement which is a quote
from the director of VG I either at a
recent meeting he said you know really
moving forward we can really he offered
the slogan for the field of synthetic
biology as life is what we make it and I
think on that note I'll start taking a
look at some of the questions here let's
see I've got you just take a look here
and some of the questions that I've got
this one doesn't
have named Nancy pardon me I'm just
getting used to this interface this is
from an eel at Manipal University if
we're able to to rewrite our DNA then
will it be possible that one day humans
will be resistant to all diseases I
think that's a fascinating idea I think
definitely as we're we're probably going
to be one of the last creatures to
completely rewrite our DNA because of
the ethical concerns in net but but
we're certainly going to start applying
this to model organisms sooner than
later and who knows as we get more
proficient at doing this and confident
in our abilities to rewrite DNA we could
very well start to do that for human
genomes and I would imagine that one of
the things we would try and do is make
ourselves resistant to some of the
biggest diseases of the day I like to
think that I like I believe that when it
comes to one of the big diseases is
cancer of course I don't know if will
necessarily be able to engineer that out
of our genomes because really we're
talking about disk corruptions but I I
think that we're it's very likely we as
we start to re-engineer genomes we'll be
able to remove some of the
disease-causing code but I think that's
really I think we have a long way to go
before we start doing that but there's
already evidence that were you know that
we'll start doing this with various
other genomes
this next question is from William at
the inland Institute of esthetic
dentistry
hi William William writes he's concerned
enough that responsible scientists are
playing with DNA let alone community
clowns this stuff is very dangerous and
amenable to simple mistakes to say
nothing of terrorist potential this is
this is definitely one of the biggest
concerns about the field of synthetic
biology that that scientists don't know
what they're doing there's the potential
for biological errors that and also that
this technology can be used to to
produce weaponized versions of different
diseases etc it's it's an absolutely
common concern so people from from the
very beginning have been discussing and
thinking about how to put in safeguards
I like to point out that the number one
safeguard that we have in all of this is
that we unlike computers we actually
have a universal defense system in most
living organisms and it's our immune
systems even bacteria have forms of
immune systems all higher organisms have
defensive systems of some type so
biology is always at war with with other
biology and and certainly you these
technologies allow for the creation of
new or novel bioweapons but they will
all be synthetic and ultimately created
through the architecture of digital
tools I'm not saying that this won't
lead to potentially some new bio weapons
but they won't be done in secret though
there will certainly be processes to go
and and and hunt down those that are
abusing it
there are already safeguards in place
between that are in the software and in
the printers and I think it's just
really I think it's really important
that the in
hire that the world stays engaged with
the potential risks around this that
being said these technologies right now
are largely being done by by scientists
that are properly trained that are
properly that have the right cultures of
responsibility this is certainly
appearing in the DIY community as well
there is a new defense community growing
up around this that is the that is
emerging quickly I think that you know
that we have a lot to learn but we're
learning a lot of the dynamics from what
we're seeing in electronic computing and
for anyone that thinks electronic
computing is less benign than these
technologies just think about how many
in how many systems today computers are
embedded so you know there's risks at
all levels of with any technology but I
truly believe that the benefits of doing
synthetic biology outweigh the risks at
this point because we're still
essentially working with toy
technologies and we have we're really
being cautious as we move forward in
being able to track individuals
communities tools dynamics etc but you
know again be engaged and and teach
people properly the next question here
is from Hmong Mong Jin Li from sisse and
the question is what is the response of
big bio corporations government agencies
etc towards the theme of openness open
source open access backed by the DIY
community that's a great question
right now big bio is has if anything
been engaged in in in actually funding
some of the explorations of this space
and and watching it very carefully but
I've I've seen some large groups go and
actually fund the ijen program they're
very interested in
and building an open architecture and I
think in some ways it's because they
realized that they're getting
essentially a and they're seeing some of
the changes in their own industries how
difficult it is to produce things they
see this technology is as potentially
allowing them to accelerate their
business we're seeing some of the
synthetic biology companies that are
appearing in this space also becoming
very very economic in tracks on just two
or three weeks ago went public it is now
worth three billion dollars we've had
other companies like amorous go public
the companies that are doing gene
synthesis are doing very well so I think
in general big bio is is looking at this
very carefully and the open source and
open access foundation you know it isn't
completely new to them in the sense that
the digital architectures that almost
every come company uses today you know
really with the web has an open
foundation on which proprietary layers
have been built so I think at this point
everyone's learning about the new
intellectual property ideas what what it
means in terms of participants what
open-source versus proprietary looks
like and you even see the appearance of
new business models so again stay tuned
to see how this plays out
certainly in computers proprietary and
open source neither one is a you know
completely deletes the other let's see
here
Gennaro from the University of Miami
asks the question what do you think of
how gene networks will influence disease
again another great question that comes
more in the area of systems biology in
fact we're still trying to figure out
many of the gene networks and how they
actually contribute to metabolism and
disease and I think I think we're just
going to see so much more effort in done
here and success because it's getting
easier and faster
to sequence genomes of our organisms the
computational tools are getting smarter
for reverse engineering them and for
running virtual experiments on the data
looking for patterns etc so I think as
we start to sequence more and and apply
more computational resources and get
better at doing the analysis we will
figure out a lot of these gene networks
and how they contribute to not only
bizzy's but to to healthy states I've I
was just up in Canada last week
participating in the Personal Genome
Project Canada I fully intend open
sourcing my genome I want to see
millions of genomes flow in to the Rd
databases so that we can start to make
more sense of this sort of thing and of
course we're seeing the opening of the
micro biomes as well William from the
Inland Institute of aesthetic dentistry
again another comment also think that we
should be spending more time on
messenger RNA to control processes less
likely to permanently damage the genome
yes very good point there's multiple
layers of control and cells really the
work that we're doing today is largely
on microbial systems and single cell
systems but we have to learn really how
to manipulate all these architectures in
robust in predictable ways if it's
synthetic biology is truly going to
thrive
Daniel Greenberg from Cobra products Inc
how do you see genetic engineering and
synthetic biology in general taking the
next step into becoming a larger
industry most of these small biotech
companies seem to be startups and
limited in their growth it's true this
is really a field that's growing
bottom-up the big companies have largely
looked at synthetic biology is just a
tool whereas some of the smaller
companies coming into the space look at
it as a foundational technology and are
driving it hard but two years ago I
started to notice a shift in that the
the some of the VCS and backers were
starting to fund smaller companies in
this space and the money was really
starting to flow in bottom-up it wasn't
just going to the big-name scientists
but starting to go to smaller groups and
I think we'll see that trend certainly
in computing and software development we
see we see things like Y Combinator that
fund hundreds of small start-up
application companies because the
infrastructure for computing exists so
really it's a very low cost process to
boot up a lot of companies I think we'll
start to see that appear in in life
science over the next few years as the
infrastructure for synthetic biology and
the use of things like fabs to boot up
these technologies virtualize it more I
think we'll start to see a lot more
money flow into the space both at the
top with big industry making investments
but also at the bottom from from VCS
coming in to smaller groups wow there's
a few more questions I won't be able to
get through them all but Hector from
Karolinska Institute on the one hand if
I'm not mistaken DNA origami only uses
DNA as a rob block material on the other
hand what do you think about DNA and I
can't see about DNA programming
concerned with implementation of boolean
gates so I won't go this into this in
detail but Hector you're right it's it's
absolutely with DNA origami it's used as
a structural material we are seeing many
applications of DNA
computing new essentially using some
tricks with DNA to to do some
calculations we've also seen just a few
months ago from Stanford the
instantiation of the first biological
transistors with really tight junctions
so we are truly seeing computation come
to these living systems
now boolean computation come to living
systems and living and biomaterials in
new ways and I think that's very
exciting we'll see a lot more
explorations probably have time for one
or two more questions here Martin from
the Nazarene University what do you
think is the biggest biological obstacle
not the technical one on the way to on
the way to synthetic organisms and do
you think we should worry about extant
organisms being replaced with synthetic
organisms I think the biggest biological
obstacle today is still we the core
technologies of DNA synthesis are still
very at the beginning you know we're
it's still very expensive to write a bit
of DNA we were we're not proficient at
doing complex circuits in this work yet
and so we can we're not just
manipulating single proteins like the
first generation biotech industry but
but we're still learning our how to make
more complex circuits so I think we have
a long path to go I don't worry so much
about X and organisms in the short term
replacing you know being being replaced
with synthetic ones but I do think we
we're going to start seeing more and
more synthetic organisms appear first in
controlled environments and later with
with you know ultimately getting
licensed for release but I think it's a
very long process what I do know is that
you know because we can have ownership
of these things it is an industry people
will make investments and I see the
emergence of boutique biotech and
biotech you know gene genetically
modified organisms that people seek out
because they have features that they
want and are willing to pay for but you
know it'll be a long process yet
and probably the last question here from
Ezra at the Instanbul tech Technical
University I think there's a dilemma
between synthetic biology and natural
life because I believe if our society
will get away with and get away from the
natural organisms and processes
consequently consequences of it will be
disaster synthetic biology field seems
perfect but sorry I just have to read
but have you ever thought about its
impact in nature absolutely and I don't
have all the answers for this what I
really believe is is that we'll find the
right balance as we move forward as a
species I think it's a technology that's
very powerful in its potentials that
we're really starting off in some of our
worst case scenario fears are probably
shaping our ideas on this right now but
like computers I see I see genetic
engineering and synthetic organisms
having large and generally positive
impacts on the world moving forward and
when we see negative impacts I think
we'll learn from them very quickly and
perhaps this last question from rubra
the Arab International University can
this technology help us increase human
lifespan can a cure diseases like
diabetes and cancer and I think
absolutely will you know these
technologies will have a big impact in
cancer in the short term and with things
like diabetes cancer in particular
because I look at that as a disease and
of one but in in terms of lifespan we've
been learning how to live you know
healthier and that's allowing us to live
longer I don't think we're going to be
engineering ourselves anytime soon for
longer life but you know where every
step of the way we're learning with our
own use of technology we're learning how
to apply it to live longer healthier
more fulfilling lives
so I think this is just another tool in
in our technology arsenal but one that
is that has very profound and
far-reaching implications thank you for
listening and I will I hope you can
to explore the field thank you very much